this episode is sponsored by google play
with the help of lourdes mobile
you've seen them visit outerspace secret
prisons on the moon even travel through
time now follow the men in black on
their most exotic out-of-this-world
destination yet Europe men in black
international sudha for the reboot of a
franchise built around Will Smith
goofing on a bunch of grumpy white guys
but they're throwing out the proven
formula in favor of something much more
daring stick to beautiful people on
screen together and hope they're funny
well it's not going to save itself are
you saying that you need me to save the
world uh-huh oh you said them give each
other thumbs up instead
I don't know it was harder for Tiger
making these too funny or Hitler Tessa
Thompson is am a code name that was
thankfully still available while chris
hemsworth is agent age a guy who's both
great at his job
knew the best agent in the building and
a lazy screw up sorry
so in this top agent slash total loser
teams up with a rookie who's by the book
slash completely reckless the results
will be so muddled it'll feel like each
actor hired their own personal
screenwriter because they did
yikes I hope you didn't pay any extra
for this one I have no dog no cat
definitely no chill you remember the men
in black the COO is ice agency with its
own child separation policy look I just
want to see my kids much they've gone
for protecting the galaxy to letting
alien frat boys have their way with us
you choked he wants to be shown a good
time are you pimping me out to fungus
but when two aliens arrive who can
disguise themselves as humans you know
like every other alien they'll use their
powers to reshape the earth around them
to steal a gun with the power to reshape
the earth around them because the g-baby
is trust in my v with a weapon i star to
protect me I can smack it in la Li Mesa
is a real bad guy at the end there and
it's a view to ours now ghosts go
through the Tessa Thompson Co Twitter
it's way more thought out and it's
actually funny and Sony just bought the
movie rights didn't they want to see
them aliens this movie's got um and
while some of them are racial
caricatures and some of them are beloved
comedians dusting off their 2012
material what is this the secret of the
notebook all of them are extremely horny
he thinks you're hot
he's just so yummy human nor doesn't
matter no just curious how it works
between species are we sure F gary Gray
actually directed this because it kind
of feels like someone's trying to get
fired
oh so dress up like the bouncer at a
country club and fetish sighs gods like
it didn't go out of style because once
the 21 Jump Street crossover fell
through and Will Smith pass to do bad
boys three you are about to experience
the minimum viable studio product that
technically qualifies as a movie
something is wrong in mending bra morons
and black have you asked me hey does
happen with a forgetting thing please
yeah can I get my memory wipe too please
oh my brain what happened why am I in a
recording booth ooh
they made a new man in black movie with
Thorin valkyrie that sounds cool
starring not Hemsworth it sorry to
bother me I did it for maybe a week
hoping some men and black bastard would
come out of a pub and have a go at me
about something you know Kumail 19
trying to be funny
well you got to bring Rebecca Ferguson
into this nanny McFly James P Sullivan
and the twins who also had to be in cats
man 2019 was not their year been in
black EU you know this is the second
Will Smith sequel to not actually
feature Will Smith but references
character with an oil painting on the
wall in fact right now someone out there
is working on his oil painting for
Suicide Squad - this episode is
sponsored by google play get Lords
mobile and discover more on Google Play
it's a long way to tipperary it's a long
way to go it's a long way to tipperary
to the sweetest girl
I'm not bad I'm just drawn that way
birthdays are healthy the more you have
the longer you live